[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we have with us the lift
gun alex acosta
right before you came in this fool had
dropped a bomb on us and told us that
he's got some developments happening
with his parents and to catch you up
okay
this is [ __ ] crazy i'm so it's so
surprising that he just kind of
nonchalantly said it too because we're
just like what the [ __ ] okay so bart
comes from a broken home all right
so bro as you could tell by the so
[ __ ] broken that his mom had to get a
re restraining order
for the dad because he was beating his
ass up so hard he got bruised up trying
to take pictures take him to court or
shouting order on him or his dad his dad
when he was a jewish dude he was doing
wushu on me because he was practicing
whatever he learned in kung fu yeah
after watching a bruce lee movie he was
[ __ ] using bart as a punching bag but
his mom did try to get a restraining
order on bar because bart was just
biting her all the time but that's
besides the point okay so after that
bart was living under his mom's roof and
then
one day
you were being a trouble boy and you
started living with your dad right after
military school getting kicked out of
too many schools or some [ __ ] yeah then
i moved in with my dad because my uh my
other cousin was a fob which means he's
a model citizen he was doing really good
at mark keppel and my dad said you come
live over here and you can learn from
him
and uh
which is an interesting arrangement
because somehow he convinced my cousin
to move out of his house to live at our
house like to literally like he might
say my dad said move in with me
to learn from your cousin he meant it
literally so he had two rooms
uh both one was a sleeping room so i had
a bed my cousin had a bed and then we
had another room a study room and it
would be two desks
so instead of me having my own room
where i have my desk in my bed and then
he has his own room where he has a desk
but he literally wanted me to like
[ __ ] chaperone his ass
or shadow his ass the whole [ __ ]
you're his apprentice
the one time that he uh pissed me off i
told him that if he wasn't my cousin i
would have whipped his ass
how old were you during this
this is probably when i was like 17 now
16. all right so 17 years old he's
living with his dad right during this
whole time mom and dad never [ __ ]
talks
fast forward i come around and i see
this whole thing go down i meet both of
his parents they never [ __ ] talk they
don't they're in the same room they
don't even they talk through bart
right
he has a wedding they finally come
together right i see his mom standing at
the beach and mad dogging his dad like
he is a disgusting piece of [ __ ]
and david could [ __ ] vouch for this
because he [ __ ] was laughing right
never talked
fast forward to what we find out
his bart moved in with him in vegas and
he's like
how about you and your uh me and your
mom get back together and out that was
the last thing he [ __ ] told us a
month ago and we're like whoa
and this morning he goes they moved in
together
yeah so my dad
what the [ __ ] right so we got my dad um
a house
but it's still being built
and so it was actually jill's idea she
was like why don't you get because
he was gonna wait out like like the two
years or whatever but you know like
during the housing market was like was
high
um in la and it was still low in vegas
yeah so she was like why don't we have
him sell this house when it's still
worth more and then just move in with us
and then buy the house in vegas when
it's still cheap so it was a really good
idea i'm like cool like everyone was
super happy he moves in
and once he moved in and i think he
liked
the comfort of it only from his side
because we find him annoying as [ __ ]
and we i didn't know there's a no inside
of him
he's like hey you know after the house
gets built
um how do you feel if like
i just keep living with you guys
and i'm like nah that's not cool yeah
i'm like that's it you gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here we had a trial and you
failed the job interview i was like you
need to get your ass out and then i
guess he started like thinking all sad
and [ __ ] and then like i think what he
imagined vegas to be is completely
different he goes dude i go to the
hospital and they don't even speak
chinese i'm like because it's america
[ __ ] he goes but yeah but in
like the 626 i'd go anywhere everyone
understands what i'm saying so i guess
it's so much easier for him to get
around like at the dmv like there's no
translators at the vegas dmv so he's
just not used to it i'm like to move
your ass back to [ __ ] monterey park
then
and um
yeah so he so he was like oh [ __ ]
am i gonna live by myself if i move back
my son just want me to live with live
with me i live with them what am i gonna
do she had this wise idea you go oh you
know what
i'm alone
i know your mom's alone she's probably
hella lonely like what what if i go and
moving with her and on my dad that's the
dumbest thing i've ever [ __ ] heard
because i was like in the last 30 years
you guys been divorced i mean how many
times has mom texted you he goes none
i'm like that means
she don't even care about
you and then he goes oh no no you don't
know you don't know what us people think
like at our age i'm like yeah she would
have told me you know my mom loves to
vet and [ __ ] talk [ __ ] all day and
i'm her first person to go to because
i'm the only child so i hear everything
from her and i'm like if she ain't
telling me that kind of [ __ ] then it
ain't going down
and then he was not i have to try
whatever so i'm like all right go you go
try
and uh
i guess lo and behold
he pitched it to her and then my mom's
like
well if you want to move in you're not
going to move in as my husband because
you [ __ ] that up so he goes i'll let you
move in as my child's father so i have
another room you stay in that room
and here is a [ __ ] contract that you
gotta follow we're gonna go to the park
and exercise an hour every day we gotta
go [ __ ] listen to these buddhist
sermons and all this [ __ ] right she said
that too oh this whole [ __ ] list of
[ __ ]
and then my dad's like you see how crazy
the crazy ass of a [ __ ] your mom is i'm
like i told you that's the person mom is
i'm like that's why i don't want her to
move in either
i'm like i already know how crazy she is
and you know how this is the reason why
you divorced but then i think my dad's
like he's just at that age where he just
wants company you know so he'll settle
yeah and then he was just like oh you
think your your life is gonna be uh
less busy am i honest yeah i don't think
so like once tiger gets older and older
i'm just to be more invested in his life
he has soccer games basketball games
whatever i'm just going to be more and
more involved like the the type of like
fantasy that you want to live i'm like
it's
i think you're just making up in your
own mind you know
it's so funny and it's crazy because
like now i don't even talk to him as an
adult it almost seems like i'm talking
to a child like he'll come to me like he
like walks all slow and [ __ ] he goes hey
this is my vision imagine like christmas
right we're eating dinner and it's me
your mom
like you jill tyka and we're having this
nice christmas dinner isn't that nice
and i'm like hey dad out of the seven
billion people in this world i'm like
you know how many people have that
vision he goes how many i'm like one
i'm like that [ __ ] is not gonna fly and
he goes
he goes
did you ever tell him like
you know
you cultivated this relationship like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i
told them i'm like
why are you why are you trying to pluck
fruits you never said like
[ __ ] planted the seeds for you know
like if you wanted this beautiful vision
of a family you need to pave the road
for 30 years to get there you can't just
come in and demand [ __ ] and so like uh
now
like it feels bad because like every
single time i feel like i'm setting my
new boundary i'm like nah dude i'm not
going to have this toxic relationship in
my life with both of my parents and i
got to keep things away so i have my
good mental space but then
that toxic term is such a like american
concept because as soon as i set that
boundary the asian boy instead of like i
can't believe it was so disrespectful to
my [ __ ]
whip myself in the back
[Laughter]
it's really crazy to hear you talk like
that like to your parents in general
like because i would never imagine bart
would ever be this mean to his dad so
mean
i'm so [ __ ] mean and i think one
billion people
i'm
only person out of billions that want
that dude my mom will [ __ ] text like
she texts me paragraphs right like of
[ __ ] and i just go ah too long won't
read
damn that didn't look long i'm like too
long won't read it's all okay all right
yeah okay yeah like she'll write like
cool watch she likes to write [ __ ] like
this
boom boom boom boom boom boom i just go
i wrote
which is i don't know
[Laughter]
boom boom boom i'm like dude i gotta set
boundaries i just feel like as a kid i
got walked over too much and i never had
my own life that now i have my own life
my own family and i like the way it's
going then i'm not gonna let [ __ ] [ __ ]
it up i think that's you and you're
right too because like messed up they
can't
oh
they can't cultivate this relationship
with you and be tyrannical and expect
you not to resent that yeah but that's
not his mom right his mom's not doing
that they're both like that in different
ways but she's not like trying to tell
you how you need to run your life or
trying to get into your life right yeah
now she's going so now i guess she my
dad's on her like they're on [ __ ]
team whatever the [ __ ] now so my mom's
like hey you got ticket your father man
you got only got one father today's
video is brought to you by masterworks
you think jeff bezos has an iced out ape
jpeg hell no that guy's way smarter than
that plus nft our old news racers is all
about diversifying now makes sense the
world lost 13 trillion dollars worth of
stock in the first half of the year and
let's not even talk about crypto that's
true that's why we keep our crypto
looking like a college admissions
brochure we got representation from all
angles diversified to the teeth exactly
that's why big daddy bezos splashed out
70 million for just two paintings no
apes involved basil's into artemis you
know yeah man he knows that art has the
lowest correlation to any asset he's a
great diversifier he can't go all in on
just [ __ ] coins maybe that works for
bezos but i'm just a podcast host
and that's where masterworks comes in
baby this platform buys actual paintings
not nfts from names like picasso and
banksy wow and breaks them into shares
so you're investing in just a piece of
the paintings this way you're
diversifying with art without
sacrificing your first born son to date
over 500 000 users has signed up for
masterworks but you jk fam can skip the
line by going to masterworks dot art
slash record again that's masterworks
dot are slash record see important
regulations and disclosures at
masterworks.com
cd
[Laughter]
so they're complaining together not just
your dad though it's just it's just your
dad that's the variable they're a form
of the avengers against you dude both of
them
like so the difference is this
my dad is older now and he makes stupid
decisions and then the re the
consequences of those decisions
he wants me to bear with him yeah right
like for like hit like now he goes man i
made a big mistake i should have never
sold that house and i'm like yeah cause
now you got an empty ass house in vegas
that ain't nobody gonna live in too you
don't have to rent it out and do all
this unnecessary things because he
didn't think it through did you tell him
not to even move to vegas originally
originally i was like [ __ ] one
guy he said don't move today
[Laughter]
i care about you guys
that's how you know i care about you
guys
i don't want my parents near me i'm
conflicted i want my friends close i
don't want those fools dude
i'll try to get my mom to stay in taiwan
i'm like what are you doing back here
way better over there you can walk
around and all that mom chyna's about to
roll through any minute now just chill
just stay there
yeah but yeah so my dad is he's in this
phase of like i make stupid decisions
but then instead of accepting the
consequences he wants me to endure them
with him so that's that side of like
pressure my mom is like what that
confucius say like it's like so she has
her horse to tell her stuff yeah rule
said fortune teller that kind of looks
like so i gotta follow and like you only
got one father oh you're chinese chinese
people need to do this i'm like
[ __ ] if you get 20 german
shepherds they'll all behave differently
you know like just because they're a
german shepherd don't mean they're going
to be german one opens a gym
[Laughter]
one because don't give me that chinese
[ __ ] man we don't have german
shepherd in the zodiac here do you see
german shepherd
what if she wants to move her fortune
teller in
oh i wouldn't be surprised she's tight
with all of them
wait so they're both moving to vegas or
they're coming back here no they so
they're staying here which is good
because it's far away oh wait did he he
moved in with her yeah you know how so
we sold our house right yeah when we
moved to the apartment my dad uh went to
my mom's house
yeah so he was already planning the exit
and the funny thing is your mom accepted
it
she gave him options and said sure and
the last day oh [ __ ] killed me so the
last day we're parting our ways my dad
left in the morning he goes
one day i'll see you again oh and i was
like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm being so bad boys
[Laughter]
oh
yeah i mean you did a lot of [ __ ] so
you're saying now you just have two big
old houses in vegas two people housing i
live in an apartment right now but
you're getting your house built and then
now you have your dad's house
yep that i gotta like rent it out for
it's not even he just has to do the work
and rent it out and his dad gets the
money yeah so i'm gonna rent it out for
him
and then i'll get director positive so
my dad could have access
to whatever
when the tenants have [ __ ] they're gonna
[ __ ] bother bart yeah pretty much
when i'm like you shouldn't have moved
in the first place so it just feels like
he's just going and leaving a trail of
[ __ ] that i'm like oh [ __ ] i gotta
fix it that's called good boy good boy
asian culture you're doing a good job
and american is called toxic
relationships oh you so [ __ ] american
now man
with the white terms come here you you
be you born here while one generation
you learn so much [ __ ] smash [ __ ] boy
what would james wang do yeah yeah i
don't know i need to call the one have
you seen them together i haven't i
haven't yet that must be [ __ ] weird
dude they're making out dudes what if
you go there and that extra room is not
extra anymore and they're just in one
bed oh
[Music]
whatever they do i honestly like i'd be
down because i told my parents too i was
like if you guys are going to make this
move i don't want to be in the middle
right the last thing i want is to be in
the middle so i'm like
i just want i just want both of you guys
to be happy and if that's alone awesome
if it's together awesome i don't care
what [ __ ] happens but if you guys got
beef
um
you guys gotta like handle it yourself
the only other thing i the only time i
would step in this is when i was telling
my dad
i'm like
mom has a short fuse she's on menopause
now she's got a mustache her [ __ ]
test levels are [ __ ] high struggling
just pulling 305 yeah i was like
i saw a pull 315.
crazy so i was like if she kicks your
ass out
um which is highly possible let me know
i'll help you find the place
um but just know that that is
the direction that it'll probably go
into yeah like happily ever after i was
like in my opinion i don't think this is
what this whole thing was measurable
yeah yeah but so far so good you gotta
just believe in love again bart what's
up what a cute story though they end up
back together dude i hope they i hope
they get married the cute story is this
guy's like happily ever after i don't
[ __ ] see you going that way at all i
believe in love not my parents if you've
been around my parents dude they love
them
[ __ ] energy is strong dude your
parents relationship reminds me of my
parents because i when i when i hear
them together i'm like dude you guys
have to move on opposite sides of the
world dude
you guys you guys cannot be
near each other it's like oil and water
wait so is your dad adhering to the
contract now so far so because you've
been working
dude he's been going to the park bro
he's been going my dad so my dad has a
uh
you know my eye is older so his
prostate's enlarged and stuff and so my
mom also made a hard rule like the
bathroom you can't use mine you have to
use the other one
right and then my dad's like dude but
sometimes i have to wake up pee in the
middle of the night or whatever and he
goes no it's too bad either that or you
bring a bucket in your room like these
are the rules
and then so my dad told me he was like
man the [ __ ] that [ __ ] the other day
we went to go work out at the park and i
was about to [ __ ] piss myself and
then uh but the bathroom was closed cuz
you know your mom likes to work like
workout at six a.m so i have to go pee
on a tree and i'm like
that's mom life you know if you want to
be a part of mom life that's what you
have to do on a tree is pretty fun dude
but an old asian mass imagine just like
nothing to see here
i gotta pee on a tree sometimes
you gotta go you gotta go so i'm like i
don't even know nothing that's still
peanuts yeah having an enlarged prostate
makes you pee more yeah because it
pushes against your bladder
i swear i'm not a mainlander i know
that's all stinky people like god the
chinese are here
yeah that's crazy so now they're hanging
out and so far so good he just texts
random things like he's like i haven't
watched tv in two weeks
do you know my mom haven't watched a
parade for two weeks well she just has
like buddhist sermons playing on every
single speaker tv in the house what is
he is that a complaint or is it is he
proud of himself
i think that's a complaint probably you
know what's funny though is you know how
they say it's always good to get dogs in
pairs because they [ __ ] take care of
themselves ever since my mom got um
remarried
barely get a phone call now so it's
amazing
so now bart's getting two times the text
messages of complaints because they're
together
well now my mom since my mom likes to
yap a lot she's just channeling whatever
my dad so now she texts for her and
someone else
oh damn see i guess it's different
because you're an only child where
before my mom was remarried it was me
and my brother getting it and then like
after she remarried nothing
it's the best
do you guys have any uh other stories
from your parents in there well my
parents are divorced but they're like
cool they're homies so oh that's boring
they got some cool tips for you know get
in there and stir things up man yeah
no yeah they've always my mom's
remarried and my dad is my
tech she's technically my half sister
right because she's from my mom but my
step-dad my actual dad is her godfather
oh yeah
so you guys worked that out real good
yeah they're they're still real cool
like we were out just out in arizona
this past weekend and we were all
chilling the whole time so
yeah it sounds like a dream
it was cool yeah i mean it was nice i
mean if they hated each other we never
knew so they've always made it seem like
they were super cool
yeah
i think like if we fast forward maybe
five ten years and my parents are a
little bit older and they're not in the
feisty old person stage oh yeah it might
be easier to deal with you mean when
they're gonna just basically breathe and
survive that's perfect yeah he's like oh
man that's because
babies yeah cause my mom's still in that
feisty stage where she's dead or she's
down to like argue like i could just
feel in the text like i already ended it
and she goes and another thing and then
oh my [ __ ] wow i'm like yeah you
still want that
[ __ ] she wants to smoke yeah you want
some get in the ring dude
bart's mom got the fire how old is your
mom
uh 70 something 71 something like that
oh sure you said she's still going
through menopause
well she went through it
she went through it so her testing
levels are high now still yeah i was
like i think even with my parents good
relationship it would be weird if they
were like together though like living in
the same house for me i don't know if i
could like
comprehend that yeah i'd feel really
weird
nick are your parents together yeah yeah
legally they're still together wow gosh
what about you ryan yeah yeah
you didn't ask me
you said your mom remarried
i just felt left out bro
your parents are still together right
how when did you guys parents like
divorce like how old were you
all of you guys i was six oh you know
what i told my parents too so my mom was
like complimenting
oh actually my dad so my dad was like oh
man like i really like your and gio's
relationship are you raising taika and
then he passed that along to my mom you
know so my mom was calling me and she
was like hey you know your dad said that
he really enjoyed living with you guys
he really liked your guys the teamwork
that you guys had and i'm like oh you
know uh how i based my relationship and
then she was like how i was like on the
opposite dad
dude costly just dunking dude wait what
you
you based your relationship on the
opposite of what my parents
fireworks you guys set the example of
exactly what not to do so i just
followed that that's [ __ ] funny
that's dope yeah doesn't feel good to
say [ __ ] like that and then afterwards
bad asian boy bad boy boy
bad boy
my mom [ __ ] beats herself up so much
that i it's not fun to me anymore i wish
so if my parents had the phase of like
oh man like realization i take
responsibility for what happened instead
of like oh my son did everything wrong a
hundred percent you know like no room
forever then i'm like
if if they switched it i would probably
back off but i never got any of that
they still think they're the right one
[Laughter]
yeah that's tough man there's no growth
with that
but yes nick my parents are still
together thank you for asking why did
you answer that like 10 minutes later
dude because everybody cut me off [ __ ]
you chased the subject dude
you like looked around the room
you just want to call me a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you